Should I be concerned about the amount of EMFs in the bedroom if the right the generator and the laptop are all on all night.
Currently, I don't even leave my router turned on at night.
So where do you get EMFs from in your house?
Well, you get EMFs that are produced locally through electronics,
through number one source of EMF in your house produced locally is your Wi-Fi.
That's the number one produced locally, EMF.
But you also get EMFs from your cell phones if they're plugged in next to you all night long,
because those are coming not locally from the cell phone but from the cell phone tower still connecting all night long.
So you shouldn't leave your cell phone plugged in next to you in bed.
So the other sources of locally produced EMFs are dirty, EMFs, dirty electricity from your wiring of your house.
Everybody's house is hardwired.
And the number one source of external EMFs that's coming from the outside of your house is a cell phone tower.
And your outside meter, your electric meter.
So getting your meter cover can be really helpful.
You can't do anything about cell phone towers that are near you except moving away from one.
Are you getting EMFs from the right machine from the generator itself?
No, you're not getting any EMFs from the generator.
Are you getting EMFs from the laptop?
Yes, if you leave the laptop on, that's why we suggest you close the laptop.
What do you need it to sleep?
It's not producing any more EMFs.
You can get an EMF reader because we've done that and measure it.
It's not producing any.
So no, you do not need to be concerned about EMFs in your bedroom from the right generator and the laptop.
If you close the laptop at night.
So again, number one source of EMFs in your house produce locally is your Wi-Fi.
So it's the right thing to do, turn your Wi-Fi off at night.
Dirty electricity.
So think about getting a mitigator for dirty electricity.
That is the things that we have in our store.
And your, your meter on the outside of your house.
Think about getting the cover guard for your meter than a little mesh cover guard that goes over it and tightens down on your meter cover.
We have that on ours.
Both at the office and our house and all my staff has them at their house too.